there is a nice paper causal effects of
mindfulness makes people more
sanctimonious
[Music]
the first section of this discussion is
are things an essential part of who we
are and if so why and I'll start with
you Steve and I guess is it worth
showing a distinction perhaps between
consumerism and objects that really have
meaning to us personal objects we look
around our house our homes our
possessions reflect who we are anyone
who's cleared out a relative or a
parent's house or after they've died
those objects really have very you know
nostalgic and positive associations and
bring and bound up with memory so should
we draw that distinction do you think
yeah I know what you mean but but you
mentioned this before the possessions
are associated with the past mate I
think Marianne maybe you mentioned that
and that's one of the issues that you
know in spirituality for example
everything is based on living in the
present you know we all know that it's
very beneficial to live in the present
that's the basic principle of
mindfulness giving you a full attention
to the present moment and one of the
issues with with possessions is that
they belong to the Past
which isn't a bad thing but if you
orientate yourself too much towards the
past then you lose sight of the present
so I think in order to be fully present
you do need to let go of possessions you
do need to be firmly focused on your
present experience rather than the past
I don't think you can really make sense
of your present unless you do understand
your past
um because otherwise you sort of
floating in a nihilistic soup and a
historical suit I mean even if it's
difficult the way to live comfortably is
sort of Happily you know be in that
present moment is to have made peace
perhaps with your past but sometimes
that requires having that the I don't
know the guy ropes and the tent pegs
that make you know who you are who you
could be or where you've come from
do you think that's there's been a
historical shift that in the past our
possessions were to do with memory
family and Things We inherited um from
our ancestors and so on nowadays our
possessions our gadgets are about being
in the present perhaps in a bad way that
we're sort of scrolling through our
social media so do you think there's
been a historical shift I think I think
since time immemorial you hunter
gatherer from the Paleolithic was kind
of eyeing up the other guy's wolf skin
going oh
oh you kept the head did you right
interesting choice I've got another one
back in the cave like I think that
that's just something essential about
humans and and the the the point you
made about
um Hans gatherers sort of live lightly I
do accept that that is true compared to
you know the boxes of crap that are in
my house for example
um but
you can look at Neolithic um Neanderthal
sites and people have curated stuff
they've buried loved ones with things
there's a there's a site in Germany
where they've arranged bits of hacked
off stalak might into a circle and so
they spent time with things making
meaning in the world in the material
world and I think if we entirely lose
sight of that we lose sight of what it
is to be human we're just complex
creatures and we tell our stories
through things I think and Paul I think
because you're a professor of Behavioral
Science I think about nudge Theory and
and how advertisers nowadays are
persuading us to buy things that we
didn't even know that we wanted or
needed so our identity is now being
formed by by our surroundings perhaps
our consumerists you know
um drivers who are pushing us to be who
we who we don't want to be yeah that's
that's an interesting question I mean it
it's clear clear that advertising I mean
Works to sell you stuff often that you
don't uh want or need to buy into a
particular lifestyle
um I mean I do it's always an
interesting question of whether
historically that was you know how much
has changed because I do think I take
the take the point about we've we we're
naturally comparative creatures that's
part of the human condition is to
compare ourselves to others so the basis
on which we do that may have of course
have changed over time but the fact that
we do that is pretty much part of who we
are
um I just want to say something quickly
on the role of nostalgia because I I'm
someone who who generally does live in
the moment I don't really think very
much about the past but the evidence is
quite compelling on the role of
nostalgia it's a it's a it's a good part
of human well-being to be reminded of
times and places that felt better or
good
and I will just say something about
mindfulness um as someone who doesn't
like it very much
um is that there's a very and of course
I see the really important point to make
about that is that there's a lot of
differences across individuals and and
anyone who tries to prescribe a
one-size-fits-all approach is selling
snake oil but there is a nice paper
causal effects of mindfulness makes
people more sanctimonious
I I it's not me it's evidence yeah I
mean I agree with Paul there is there is
a there's a danger in any Endeavor of
becoming sanctimonious and yeah I've met
spiritual people who are very
sanctimonious and they're very attached
to their spirituality and their idea of
themselves as a spiritual as a spiritual
person but there's no there's no there's
no denying that there's tons and tons of
evidence of the benefits of mindfulness
even even in situations of pain
mindfulness has been shown to be
beneficial in alleviating the symptoms
of
illnesses so yeah it's a question of
balance everything is a crystal balance
I mean I agree with you that we do need
to be reminded of who we are we do need
a kind of structure to give us a sense
of identity and meaning
but I mean the problem is when we're too
orientated towards the past the problem
is when we're too orientated towards the
future we need a sense of the future and
the past but we need to be rooted
primarily in the present
and I guess the mayor go ahead and that
idea was sort of like being focused too
much on the future ties into Peak stuff
that you're always trying to acquire
you're always aiming towards the better
car the bigger Telly I want to do I do
want to ask you about why you like your
big Telly
um but because
you're not focused sort of in the
present either what no I meant that I
meant that in a good way because yeah
yeah in my living room oh right I see
yeah it was kind of meant to be
accomplishment but it came out really it
came out really badly all right let's
let's go back edit that bit out
nice and so yes no I I take your point
yeah is that striving is it striving to
acquire more that's future base isn't it
wanting more it's always wanting more
from the future but a bit of striving is
good right it's driving me as good as
some senses but not in terms of like
striving to acquire more things that you
don't really need if it's striving
within a community maybe not so much the
bankruptcy because your neighbors just
worry but if you see that the people who
I know this isn't quite how the world
works but you know the people who've got
jobs and their kids work hard at school
and they've got the big telly to
simplify life enormously to a point of
perhaps you know nonsense that is that's
a useful thing so
this is essentially hearstman's
hearstman's tunnel so imagine yourself
in a traffic jam introduce Hershman well
it's just the time this is this is just
the name of the of what I'm about to
explain you're stuck in the traffic jam
um with two lanes both of which have
stopped
the other lane starts moving before
yours does
what goes off in your mind
well two things first of all I'm really
pissed off I would sort of been in the
other lane that's the relative effect
but also there's a signaling effect that
your lane might start moving soon
and so when we look at relative effects
of other people's consumption and other
people's income most of the time in most
of the world it's the I wish I was in
the other lane
but in in certain cultures in certain
countries in poorer parts of China in
India there's a signaling effect when
other people do well it's a signal that
I might do too
so a question coming back to Identity
about you know do our objects say
something about who we are as
individuals or do we live in communities
where the group influences the
possessions that we own absolutely
because you form your identity by
having that reflected back to you by
others I'm sure you'll disagree on that
um
but you also form your identity by
identifying who is them not us
so if those people over there have flash
cars and that's not your kind of a thing
then you may well go
uh to take a kind of strong stronger
position in opposition to that we're not
the flash car kind of people we're the
tumbly down you know you know fix it
together with a bit of um you know twine
and gaffer tape and drive around you
know north of Scotland with it where
those people you know and Counter
Culture I guess would be an example of
that yeah exactly I mean Steve I was
going to ask you because in a way
mindfulness and meditation and
minimalism it's almost become an
industry in itself nowadays and some
people might use that affiliation to
meditation practice there's a way to
Signal their identity so even though
they lack many possessions and they go
for minimalism subscribing to that
culture might be a way of signaling who
they are possibly yeah but I would say
that that's not really an authentic
practice there's this phrase I can't
remember who came with this phrase that
spiritual materials it's when spiritual
people use spiritual arts in a
materialistic way to sort of you know
project an image or to you know to
collect um you know collect experiences
or move towards Enlightenment but that's
not the way it should be you know you
should practice spirituality with no
real goal just for the fact you know
just for the experience of well-being
that it gives you in this moment so I
think really you know spirituality is
about letting go of external identity
really and covering your authentic
essential identity you know Buddhism
talks about relative happiness which is
externally based on things or events or
possessions but there's also an absolute
internal happiness which doesn't depend
on external things it's just a natural
quality of being which you uncover and
the more you focus on external sources
of Happiness the less access you have to
this internal happiness
thank you I'm gonna quickly come back on
that Marianne I had that experience I
was making a documentary in Tibet and I
was interviewing a baker in lhasa and he
had been working incredibly hard to use
the The Barley flour the roasted barley
flour that's sort of traditional there
and work out ways to make it rise with
yeast it's hard to do because you're at
high altitude and he'd done it and he'd
sort of like put together this like
really offbeat Cafe that sold
a really quirky take on traditional
Tibetan
um Foods
and I said you must be really proud of
what you've achieved here and he looked
utterly blank just it didn't make any
sense to him that question he was like
no that but we had to cut and like carry
on the interview yeah because it just
didn't make any sense being proud of
what he'd done because he hadn't done it
even though he was surrounded by what I
saw the fruits of his labor it just he
had a different world view entirely and
it did stop me in my tracks yeah
on Instagram his stuff yeah his stuff
wasn't his to kind of own or claim yeah
so fair point wow yeah
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas